on monday thousands of clark county
school district students go back to
campus hybrid learning begins for k
through third graders and as that data
approaches we're answering your
questions about a safe return to the
classroom yeah a lot of questions about
this bianca holman spoke with a
pediatrician here in las vegas
about how to prepare your child good
morning bianca
hi good morning alex good morning john
so after your child eats breakfast in
the morning before they hop on the bus
parents are being asked to conduct a
health screening on their child that
means
taking their temperature grabbing just a
regular thermometer and checking to make
sure
that their temperature is in appropriate
range now clark county school district
has
outlined a safety procedures on their
reconnect website
from travel on the bus recess time lunch
distribution
there are several steps to protect
teachers and students which align to the
cdc guidelines
social distancing hand washing and
wearing masks but
parents are the first line of defense
parents are going to be asked to do a
health assessment for
their children 30 minutes before they
load onto the bus
or 30 minutes before they attend school
that just means make sure your child
isn't sick
make sure your child doesn't have cough
runny nose sore throat
vomiting diarrhea or fever greater than
100.4 degrees
because if any of those symptoms are
present your child
should stay home
now the doctor we spoke with says that
if the child is not being cooperative
allowing you to put the thermometer
under the underneath the tongue
you can place it in their armpit and
take their temperature that way kids
will be wearing masks almost 90 percent
of the time while at school only taking
it off to eat or drink so she says make
sure your child has a properly fitting
mask
that fits over their nose and mouth that
they don't need to ask the teacher for
help
and coming up in the next half hour
we're going to share the talk
that you should have with your child
before the first day of school reporting
live from near galwan in buffalo bianca
holman
8 news now